vice president mike pence tried to lead
by example on friday
when he received the first shot of the
coronavirus vaccine
he was joined by his wife karen and
surgeon general dr jerome adams
a parade of lawmakers would follow
including house speaker nancy pelosi
and senate majority leader mitch
mcconnell the efforts come as congress
bought itself
more time to tackle two big projects yet
another coronavirus stimulus plan
and averting a government shutdown chip
reid is at the white house with more
this morning
chip good morning well good morning late
friday night president trump signed a
stop
gap spending bill that gives congress
two days to do two things
one avoid a government shutdown and two
pass a covid relief package that
has eluded them for months
all in favor say aye aye all opposed no
by voice vote the senate unanimously
passed the short-term measure to keep
the government afloat
and allow negotiations to continue on a
spending bill
and a coronavirus relief package both
sides of the aisle are firmly committed
to finalizing
another major pandemic rescue package
for the american people
as of right now we have not yet reached
a final agreement
regretfully the eas are 320 and the nays
are 60.
earlier friday the house overwhelmingly
passed the bill
i urge my colleagues join me in
supporting the ongoing
talks by adopting this clean continuing
resolution there's a little bit more
time required
to get this legislation finalized and
drafted
bipartisan leaders in the house and
senate have been negotiating a 900
billion dollar relief package for weeks
there remain sticking points however
including a republican-backed provision
to wind down the federal reserve's
emergency lending power
during the pandemic some senate
democrats accused republicans
of trying to insert a poison pill in the
bill connecticut democrat chris murphy
tweeted
it's fascinating how republicans were
fine with this fed power when trump was
president
but now all of a sudden it's bad almost
like they want to use the kovid relief
package to sabotage
biden's presidency both sides are under
pressure to get
something passed before the holiday
break majority leader mcconnell
and i do not agree on much
but as i understand it we are in
agreement
on at least one point and that is that
the senate cannot go home
until a coveted emergency relief bill is
passed
so congress now has two days to pass a
covid relief package that will probably
include another round of stimulus checks
and a 1.4
trillion dollar spending bill and get it
here to the white house for the
president's signature
as soon as possible jeff chip thank you
very much